given that you didn't have an
opportunity to play in this event do you
think that was a positive or a negative
for you and how does it affect your
chances going into the Sinquefield cup
looking at how poor everybody played I
think I would have played I would have
played even poorer so I think for me
it's good I skipped that one yeah for
sure I think it's certainly a good thing
I didn't play because I think I also
probably would have lost a lot of points
like everybody else I have to say
watching them play chess I was relieved
not to be playing because it it looked
like a cauldron out there we will now go
to the seven who will be playing in the
Sinquefield Cup the remaining seven I
joined them so we'll start with you
Maxime microphones closest given that
you did play in the st. Louis wrapping
the Blitz how do you feel about having
played and its chances the chances it
gives you to do well here in the
Sinquefield Cup Oh what can I say about
my face I actually think it was
summarized best by Grandmaster many
years ago I think it was after the game
against Hikaru actually which he
seriously missed played and he said if I
don't kill myself tonight I'll live a
thousand years I'm still here so I'm
actually looking forward to the next one
with confidence magnets the same
question to you apparently I didn't
[Laughter]
but if I were to speak for my evil twin
brother than he and he were to play the
the sinker he would probably not be so
so pleased with his results but he would
he would look forward to to the future
and he's been pretty good at the in the
past of living the past behind and
focusing on the future so I think he
would do the same this time for chess
part I was very pleased with my
performance but since we have been
aboard for some so long and will stay
here for another two weeks I started to
worry about the rice I bring here rice
we're in Boise enough do you think we
could get dinner in some rice Rex and
Jeanne told me there was nobody who want
plates in the classical in the same year
so I think I'm in a pretty good position
I look forward to the main event